dozen you [ __ ] Wow oh this is heya so
that morning today is another beautiful
day honey
that's just my signature open air across
the whole trip good morning good moring
me from beautiful teddy to save another
beautiful day and payee but anyways
we're heading out now we're going to be
going to the news today so you can
finally see the Mona Lisa in person you
excited yeah something you've been
looking forward to for this entire trip
yeah Heidi Isaac has been hiding this
cloth in this morning he woke up with a
boo-boo fever so he's not feeling too
good and we got him some cosmetics in
yesterday's just got to find him some
fever medicine now and hopefully he
feels better no no no no screaming
monitor there got a road dick happiest
oh close you go doing tiny good job all
right so this is our last full day in
Paris man like this trip 1000 just flew
by we've spent so much time doing the
wedding planning and like just a lot of
like preliminary you kind of stuff
before the actual vacation started and
it still feels like we just started our
vacation now it's already ending so I'm
going to try and relish everything today
make sure to eat extra food a whole week
tour and soaking in all the Parisian fun
so tip so that I'm jealous or anything
hey you I think what have we noticed
about the Parisian guys out here that
they dress really good oh yeah
so it's entire week every morning we see
people heading the work and I see a lot
of younger guys
really nice fitted juice and maple
what's so attractive and every time I
see it one of those guys are always
plenty feel like you need to get a suit
like that they look so good I'm
constantly taking a better onion but I'm
also checking out girls a lot too
because I'm constantly pointing out like
all the tall beautiful my girl is I keep
it her ID because what I've noticed here
is there's a lot of mixed girls they're
very ambiguous looking now here's like
African and French like they have like
their afro and my green eyes and oh my
gosh is just gorgeous so I'm taking
drugs out and I'm also picking out where
they dress I'm like okay when we come
back for our wedding I hate shopping
I need a reserved wonderful day to shop
two different styles of clothes what
they have here
it's like very European and it's like
really well fitted for like my type of
body to it back home it's so hard for me
to find clothes there's a lot of the
clothes they're designed for like more
curvier girls and I have that curvy so I
feel like I really need to just shop
here let me come back for me every you
because give me to get a student yeah
have to agree the guys I hear do look
pretty good I found myself looking at
them I'm like I got to take notes take
you take note please shoes the pants the
jacket the hair the beard I can't grow a
beard but I wish I could
[Music]
[Music]
the umbrella ladies
[Music]
all right we are now at the loo looks
like we just got inside just in time
because it started pouring cream
[Music]
pointing at us eyes like that we could
say the statues we we he's like what
come I can't look it's either really he
was like I thought you were saying yes
in French if you like we read honey I
got you know we we know on camera
remember and we read here baby what what
I really hear a little bit a lot more
[Music]
Commission to get the Mona Lisa Sarina
restore everything intimacy the Mona
Lisa I mean I'm trying to appreciate it
little by little as I'm walking but
honestly I don't nothing about Bart so I
can't appreciate it as much as other
people would I guess but I'm just like
trying to get someone over here I just
want to be her in person
it's and photos and then really soak in
the rest of the video pretty much my
plan all right so being the Mona Lisa
it's kind of like a bit of a test if
you're through anger management skills
because it's going to be a lot of people
are you ready for that are you ready to
be tested with a huge hired group of
Chinese people there's a lot of times
you'll hear in like they have their own
kind of set of rules when it comes to
traveling doesn't mix well with the rest
of the world such as I look like one of
them try singing map I'm not from China
point is are you ready for that I'm
probably not going to
I'm going to do my that I'm a very old
solo up there it is the small remaining
away in the end of the quarter Isaac
ready with his cameras locked loaded I
do all right you do the framing
oh here we go down there crack yeah oh
boy later turn I know how it's going to
be very sorry one thing to get in it's
another thing to get out
[Music]
yeah laughter negative how was it really
like everyone says it's a lot smaller so
little antics like mr. Casey no you know
what most of the time I was focused on
just getting photos for the last few
seconds I had they're always like stare
at it okay in its right thing when
you're in there you feel all the
breathing you feel all that [ __ ] out
there man I need to get in there too
because I think settings already comes
from assesses they're trying to be
polite and considerate of others because
they know that they also want to take
photos so I'm going to give venture
without humans that it just kind of be
night and that they're not just trying
to get ahead of everyone all right so
now that we've seen the Mona Lisa we can
leave the Louvre right to invoke a food
callously simply dilute overdone alright
this play today
oh he was there yes funny you think I
don't care I've been here three times by
the time you I am ia you've been here
eight times hopefully let me use I know
a lot of boobies let it we we miss okay
Isaac looking you through it in high
school I spent a life drawing class and
making people got in front of me when I
was in high school and I have to draw
the naked really yeah
[Music]
so you look like you're a baby
nice and you're here for a whole year do
you remember that no you simply put me
on my bed and click together
you got weirded out you're like
yeah thank you it's your walk oh yeah
you have your little sizzling I'll be
doing the same thing music stop talking
about stop talking together I got honor
he said yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you
like honey bee left I invested look at
this him he's staring at the carpet
instead of the ceiling like when else
are we going to be here baby come on
well that's why yeah you'll appreciate
it when you're older and you're looking
at this footage with your Isaac we are
sitting down to eat some lunch and
everyone is on a device and I thought
I'd be on devices oh and I talked to the
camera for a bit all the way to here -
all right I'm excited about the earrings
Wow do we have a meal tonight thanks
awfully secure dish last time I came in
France I only did be steak and french
fries very like American friendly foods
and this time I made it a point of
really fine restaurants that could offer
a very fresh experience this is pretty
French literally it's pickled fish
that's Ross I kind of like the Baja
mackerel at a sushi restaurant tickled
raw fish with potatoes and it's amazing
and even comes a bone my dad was
laughing at the fact that if any
American comes here in order for sure
they're going to be throwing it up and
now he doesn't know how to eat around
the bone so that's a very American
system like bonuses on reason chicken
fingers chicken nugget fish sticks and
all those are American inventions and I
feel like every other country in the
world would eat around bone the
glorifying anchovy on potatoes I was
like I thought I think you can actually
eat the phone here they're very thin and
very soft so when I eat shrimp I
actually eat the shrimp shells
regardless if it's fried or boiled or
whatever and if you should shoot through
it you can actually heat it and the
bones here that is sticking out you can
actually anything because I don't think
the French with syrup it where you have
to split out bone here kinds of crunch
to it
[Applause]
parenting fresh food is like a $50 per
head as a meal but over here you get
better quality for half the price and
it's amazing it is amazing
sleep it is Nikki you know you're doing
something right with food when I even I
think like the third huh
nothing so I'm always taking a photo of
us and is because impressive please in
this moment we gotta miss music
[Music]
oh great I'll go over a couple
[Music]
[Applause]
suitors that's very picturesque element
in the birds in a bird a real goddess a
big guy ought to be getting ourselves
into now happy weathers Ally and I
noticed there's some guys to get out of
the building
oh is it really skinny guy you have no
but put your dancers go wrong dad so now
we're on our way to the Basilica what
was it called something Oh clean please
[Music]
honestly this is nearing the end of our
trip and I don't think I've ever been
this exhausted on a trip I feel really
brain-dead I think this is the first
uh-oh
I think this is the first time we've
ever traveled with Isaac in this kind of
environment where you were placed in a
position of being a navigate everything
yeah yeah never done this before
no wonder because I'm trying to think
like why am I so tired like I'm pretty
energetic and like that's what really
comes out of me whenever we travel but
I've been thinking like why do I feel so
exhausted and that's right I have been
our tour guide for the family so I've
been the one giving directions
everywhere I'm the one telling us like
okay here we go here we go there and I
think Nora I'm so tired I'm using my
ringtone
yeah because like all the other trips
you've ever done with like Jay came
everything it's always us visiting
someone's home town or you visiting
boiling-hot oh so there's a lot of
family members everywhere we go or we go
is you know a big group and it's all
pre-planned run towards the stuff that's
very easygoing for everyone now you've
become a real traveler
oh yeah alright we're now and yes
Pacifica is something we're going up to
the dome and we're about to go up into
their case that's what like you wrap
around forever because are you pieces
oh my goodness a lot of debt
oh my gosh just started already tired
I'm pacing myself cuz you're gonna wanna
get our precious
if in Chico noise that polish more stuff
okay not so much da Vinci Code there's
more holy crap okay breathtaking run
towards it
breakfast
[Music]
I think you're looking at all of Paris
right before your eyes we redid the same
thing at the Eiffel Tower which is a lot
more intimate you don't have a lot of
people likes getting in your way time to
take pictures is this a token everybody
oh I was just super boring
[Music]
another saying you gotta sometimes
softens on flowers well mama actually
does that I think that's pretty
beautiful she knows how to appreciate
literal flowers the mome you going for
Isaac what do you want to do here Artie
the trainees are people oranges are
concerned because we're going to go to
the very top top Andy said I really want
to go obviously they're nice like who do
you work out there master
come on burns great burger all this time
you're like on our stand parent I can't
ever keep up what's up you pressing on
startup finally there so over there's a
drastic part same song Wallace is
gorgeous
yeah
[Music]
look at that traffic that still amazes
me how there are no lanes here and it's
like if the equivalence is like 12
length the width of 12 lanes and closed
in a perfect circle and yet there's no
lines drawn in the street people drive
and there's no wreck amazing it's so
beautiful here we came at the perfect
time because it's getting close to
sunset and we really thought that we
weren't even gonna be able to come today
because on the weather episode it's
gonna rain liar
I know light well according to locals
here it's really hard to predict Paris's
weather is all over the place but we
came at a perfect time because it's so
blue and the clouds are so white and
fluffy and like the gradient of the sky
because it's the sun's going down
Oh gorgeous you can get half of it I put
my phone away now come on like no tennis
okay true I need to do the same - yeah I
know we're vlogging bye guys we want
this IKEA
that's how the Tianjin you lose your
head
[Music]